o dia todos é a minha missão aqui é
tentar descortinar o que vai acontecer
com a economia do rio de janeiro os
próximos anos
eu queria agradecer o convite e
advertimos que eu seria otimista
isso significa que a gente não descarta
um entendimento dos problemas que temos
no brasil rio com as questões de saúde
educação a segurança e por aí vai
mas aqui não é nós seríamos otimistas e
gostaríamos porque vou começar falando
um pouco do estado e econômicos do rio
de janeiro o rio de janeiro o estado do
rio de janeiro é um pequeno estado da
federação brasileira
às vezes a gente esquece isso mas o rio
de janeiro é o terceiro menor estado do
brasil somos maior apenas do que alagoas
e sergipe
temos 44 mil quilômetros quadrados
no entanto temos o segundo pib do brasil
que mede é a força econômica dos estados
brasileiros o segundo estado brasileiro
embora muito pequenos
temos hoje cerca de 11% do pib
brasileiro e temos a terceira maior
população brasileira são paulo minas
gerais e rio de janeiro fazendo um
pequeno espaço geográfico portanto temos
uma grande intensidade econômica e uma
grande população é também queria chamar
atenção é da importância econômica dessa
região para o brasil se a gente fizer um
círculo de 500 quilômetros de raio em
torno da cidade do rio de janeiro
cerca de 55% do pib brasileiro não
estarão dentro desse luxo mostra a
importância econômica da região não é ea
centralidade da cidade do rio de janeiro
também é importante a gente observar o
baixo e
de desemprego em último a é na última
pesquisa feita pelo ibge é o nosso
desemprego foi de 3 pontos 2% na região
metropolitana o que significa
praticamente pleno emprego tá certo
queria também chama a atenção do pib per
capta do rio de janeiros temos 25 mil
reais a de pib per capta o que é mais ou
menos 20% acima da média brasileira e
que é um pib pequeno per capta é
importante a gente saber isso né
nós somos um país de renda média
é importante a gente seria porque as
nossas carências estão fortemente
associadas a esta questão não teme a
gente esquece disso
mas o nosso país é um país de renda
média é eu diria é intermediária se a
gente olhar os países do mundo
apresentação eu vou começar falando um
pouco da história econômica do rio de
janeiro também uma coisa muito
importante pra gente compreender o que
nós estamos aqui é ele deve aprender
também discutiu também um pouco né
uma questão que nos aflige ao longo do
tempo e está se invertendo nesse momento
que a questão da decadência econômica do
rio de janeiro
esse gráfico que estou mostrando esse
site que estou mostrando ele é um slide
é que foi feito em 1872 uma pesquisa
feita em 1872 por dom pedro 2º que
representa os primeiros censo feito no
brasil ea gente observa aquelas bolinhas
vermelhas ali em cima daquele primeiro
quadrado no retângulo né é a o estado do
rio de janeiro ea concentração de
escravos existentes no rio de janeiro em
1872 significa o seguinte a grande
densidade de escravos no brasil no final
do século 19 ela estava um estado do rio
de janeiro
a nossa economia economia do estado era
fortemente dependente tá na mão de obra
escrava
o que aconteceu quando se dá na abolição
da escravidão a economia do rio de
janeiro tem de bacuri
o dado pra vocês em 1889 ano que a gente
proclama a república no brasil a cidade
do rio de janeiro era oito vezes maior
que a cidade de são paulo em 1920
o piloto de são paulo já era maior que o
pib do rio de janeiro
por que isso enquanto nós estávamos
ainda no ciclo da escravidão são paulo
já tinha 15 capitalista já tinha se
grandes né é a nova fronteira do café e
na verdade economia não falei isso na
economia para fortemente baseada no café
na mão de obra escrava do rio de janeiro
são paulo já tinha o 5 capitalista
começando com os imigrantes na estrada
de ferro foi construída por dom pedro 2º
indo pro oeste paulista que foi a nova
fronteira do petróleo então a nossa
decadência é importante que se diga
começa aí exatamente quando se aborda os
escravos no brasil que infelizmente a
nossa economia era baseada na mão de
obra escrava e aí observa o estado do
rio o estado do rio que circundava as
cidades do rio de janeiro e
historicamente tem uma implicação
econômica política só não tem também um
dado importante de 1831 1974 e 71 foi
quando o rio passou a não ser mais
capital do estado do rio de janeiro em
1985 quando houve a fusão só nesse
interregno é que no hoje é uma eu diria
uma interconexão política entre a cidade
do rio o estado do rio
em toda a história é assim tem que ter
conexão existiu e portanto é é o que a
gente tinha naquele momento no início da
república brasileira era o estado do rio
absolutamente falido eo rio de janeiro
vivendo na das receitas públicas por ser
capital do brasil
então enquanto a gente tinha o seu
capitalista no brasil a gente tinha
estado do rio falido eo rio de janeiro
vivendo nas receitas públicas
isso vai até 1960
é de uma maneira não planejada também é
importante dizer a capital do brasil sai
do rio de janeiro vai para brasília
diferentemente de outros você assume
lembro agora o processo que aconteceu na
alemanha quando a alemanha oriental se
funde com a alemanha ocidental é ea
capital da alemanha ocidental que era
bom passa a ser berlim houve um
planejamento para isso aqui no brasil
hoje quer dizer o rio de janeiro perdeu
as receitas públicas e não teve nada que
se colocou é o seu lugar
e essa decadência se acentua em 75 a
fusão da cidade do rio de janeiro o
estado do rio de janeiro
e essa fusão também causa problemas
porque como eu já me referir o estado do
rio vivia numa penúria nada e se funde
uma cidade que foi capital do estado
eu diria que o áudio da decadência se dá
no final da década de 80
quanto à bolsa de valores o sistema
financeiro saia do rio de janeiro e vão
para são paulo aí é a nossa absoluta de
cadeiras que a gente foi sentido ao
longo do tempo
então essa história que eu queria contar
pra vocês
agora eu queria contar o novo momento
que um novo momento começa com uma
questão que a gente enxergar rua mas
agora ela se mostra absolutamente
relevante que a questão do petróleo no
meio da década de 70 foi descoberta na
bacia de campos ea bacia de campos
ela tem se tornado ao longo do tempo
cada vez mais importante e ela deu
naquilo que hoje a gente tem que é o
pré-sal que é uma riqueza que do ponto
de vista eu diria até já o político
tenha maior importância para o brasil e
para o rio de janeiro eu diria também
para o mundo
então a gente é sai com a perspectiva só
para se ter uma idéia hoje que nos
próximos 20 anos no brasil a gente tem
investimento de 55 milhões de dólares
por ano tá certo é no no setor petróleo
55 milhões de dólares por ano segundo a
agência internacional
dia de hoje até 2035 80% disso serão no
rio de janeiro
portanto o crescimento do rio de janeiro
está contratado por os próximos 20 anos
a nossa grande luta a nossa grande luta
e aí sim está introduzindo é a questão é
a diversificação da economia do rio de
janeiro para que a gente tenha
prioridade nesse processo é o rio
a lei do petróleo como a gente costuma
dizer que a luta do rio além do petróleo
ela tem duas frentes fundamentais a
primeira fez fundamental é a busca da
indústria de transformação para o rio de
janeiro ea segunda a busca da indústria
do conhecimento por isso saiu aí sim já
introduzido economia do século 21
eu vou mostrar aqui pra vocês
a previsão de investimentos o rio de
janeiro de 2014 e 2016 é observe esses
dados são feitos pela federação das
indústrias do rio de janeiro
observe o crescimento do histograma e
2014 e 2016
nós teremos cerca de 235 milhões de
reais em investimentos segundo a firjan
no rio de janeiro
de novo aquele pequeno espaço geográfico
e mostrei isto é um número espetacular
em qualquer lugar do planeta
queria voltar portanto ao nosso desafio
nosso desafio é trazer a indústria de
transformação por que por que países e
portanto o estado como rio de janeiro
ferindo as médias como mostrei pra vocês
precisam para o seu desenvolvimento
econômico de indústria quilos a história
mostra isso é só pra também lembrar pra
gente comparar aquele número que eu
mostrei alguma coisa onde 12 mil 13 mil
dólares por habitante por ano de renda
de pib
os países desenvolvidos têm renda média
de 40 a 50 mil dólares
então o salto que a gente precisa dar
precisa da indústria que a grande luta e
eu diria a grande perspectiva otimista
queria dizer é que a indústria ea
diversificação está acontecendo é o rio
ele se torna o segundo pólo automotivo
do brasil com os investimentos que foram
anunciados na indústria automotiva
o rio se torna o segundo pólo
siderúrgico brasileiro
o rio se tornará o primeiro pólo
petroquímico brasileiro quando o brasil
voltar a ter petroquímica né
o rio é ter um forte investimento hoje
na indústria de alimentos e o rio está
introduzindo a economia do século 21 se
torna cada vez mais um pólo importantes
na área de biotecnologia
então a diversificação ela está
acontecendo a partir da alavanca do
petróleo e com relação à economia do
conhecimento bom aqui eu estou mostrando
o quadro antes disso é das
potencialidades do rio de janeiro nos
vários setores esse quadro a gente
costuma mostrar os diversos investidores
estrangeiros né que nós mães que nós
visitamos que nos visitam
observe que tem uma série de coisas na
área da indústria em uma série de coisas
nela de serviço nem vale a pena dizer
porque ela é serviço grande centro da
área de serviço é a cidade do rio de
janeiro
e aí a gente fala de entretenimento de
resseguros de turismo e tecnologia da
informação
também vale a pena a gente mostrar que
na área de infraestrutura tem uma grande
potencialidade a área do aeroporto
aeroportos regionais do mercado
imobiliário de saneamento enfim isto
quer dizer é que a perspectiva é muito
boa de crescimento econômico do rio
aí tá eu diria
o a economia do século 21 tá certo dos
estado absolutamente importante é que é
dos 21 centros de pesquisas
internacionais que vieram para o brasil
nos últimos cinco seis anos 18 vieram o
rio de janeiro os seus mais diversos
segmentos
é claro no segmento do petróleo ea gente
tem que sempre da petrobras é mas também
na semana passada nós anunciamos a
andrej que é uma empresa internacional
brasileira mais internacional aa jé é a
l'oreal enfim o rio está se tornando
felizmente não é um centro de
desenvolvimento de conhecimento na sede
solidificando por 30 dias
a nossa metrópole como já me referi ela
tem um enorme interligação esse também
não falei essa figura que eu estou
mostrando aqui ela fica na ilha do
fundão 1 onde a gente tem hoje talvez o
parque tecnológico
mais importante que há no brasil um dos
mais importantes do mundo principalmente
na área do petróleo mas a metrópole
a cidade do rio de janeiro algumas
coisas importantes eu queria dizer para
vocês primeiro né que não se resolve a
cidade do rio de janeiro sem região
metropolitana é absolutamente essencial
a gente entender que a integração da
região metropolitana com hits alive
resume a resolução principalmente dos
problemas da região metropolitana é uma
questão vital para que a gente possa
desenvolver de forma civilizada a cidade
do rio de janeiro
queria também chamou a atenção de vocês
que a cidade está se movimentando na
fortemente os investimentos em
mobilidade que talvez ainda não anunciou
se ficado estão sendo feitos modificam
de forma relevante assinado e os brt
metrô a supervia as novas barcas
isso tudo vai ter um impacto importante
em toda a área fundiária é do rio de
janeiro que também chama a atenção que
tem um investimento que está sendo feito
é demorado mas absolutamente essencial
que é a questão do saneamento da baía de
guanabara saneamento da baía de
guanabara vai mudar completamente
a configuração da sociedade é é as
coisas vão acontecendo talvez não na
velocidade que a gente como cidadão
espere mas a baía de guanabara que tinha
bem pouco tempo 10% e 14% dos seus gols
tratado chegando a 60% a gente quer
sempre sendo rapidamente todos queremos
mas é um dado da realidade eu queria
chamar a atenção que 100% da bahia
tratada implicará fortemente não dança
não é deforma desenvolvimento da cidade
do rio de janeiro para concluir
eu queria dizer que as perspectivas do
ponto de vista econômico são muito boas
são muito boas
queria frisar outra vez que o
crescimento está contratado que o grande
desafio que temos é fazer com que a
nossa economia se diversifique e que
isso impacta a cidade do rio de janeiro
que forma positiva que forma aqui o
pré-requisito do desenvolvimento
econômico que permita que a gente tem
uma cidade que seja boa para criar
filhos diretos muito obrigado a todos